this video brought to you by the fine
folks at team locks key blocks is an
affordable subscription-based service
that delivers custom t-shirts straight
to your doorstep with licensed art from
Marvel DC Disney Star Wars Naruto Game
of Thrones Breaking Bad and a whole lot
more you can support my channel today
and get 10% off your first order with a
special promo code Godzilla tbx go get
some cool shirts boys and girls for the
first time since mask of the phantasm if
you don't count big hero 6 and Lego
Batman an animated film based on a
superhero comic is breaking into
theaters great job 2nd and / or 4th
place from the folks who brought you the
lego movie and somewhere around 50% of
the Han Solo movie comes into the bad
name purse this animated film is based
on the well loved and entertaining
crossover story
spider-man shattered Dimensions I mean
this came first it's the same concept by
the same writer I have a feeling I'm
gonna like this more than the comic art
because it has a clear main character
and it probably won't be hopping around
between 500 other ones and getting all
confusing and boring and I gotta tell
you I'm actually excited for this like
this looks cool there's art direction it
has a visual style that isn't generic
looking and there's a little bit of edge
to it I might be more excited for this
than most live-action superhero movies
coming out next year like Avengers
infinite cast or aqua maroon with those
you always know what you're gonna get
they look visually the same they have a
pretty common tone and style after so
many years of MCU and DC EU there's no
sense of adventure you always pretty
much know exactly what you're buying a
ticket for gray and blue color palette
with slapstick comedy forced in and
generally underwhelming villains or the
alternative black and blue color palette
with generally underwhelming everything
and unprofessional quality editing
that's right I'm going after everyone
today Marvel your movies they look like
a Civil War Reenactment no like the
actual one there's blue and grey
everywhere that's what makes this little
animated film special it's an outlier
and you don't know exactly what to
expect
it's the same kind of excitement I felt
watching trailers for Logan or Deadpool
they're outside the norm and they do
things differently there's a focus on
visual style that looks like a moving
comic-book speed lines attached to
fast-moving objects exaggerated
character proportions the neat red and
blue cyberpunk look of it I also like
the jerky animation because it's an
intentional stylistic choice to mimic
hand-drawn animation they're playing
with the frame count on character motion
to create a unique look as opposed to
say lacking the budget for smooth
animation the biggest takeaway from this
trailer is the prominence of fan
favorite spider-man Mills Murrells Peter
Parker is only in one wide shot of the
subway while miles is the main focus
even the movie's logo is on miles chest
signaling that this will most likely be
his story
you can't discuss this movie without
discussing miles and the problems he may
have is the main character of a movie so
instead of a typical trailer analysis
let's talk about our new main character
and what I hope this film does with him
a lot of my established audience members
know that I'm not the biggest fan of
Miles Morales as a character and one of
my most substantial problems is that
whenever I say this somebody always asks
is it because he's black come on guys
you wouldn't ask that question if
someone said they dislike cyborg or
spawn because those are better written
characters and they aren't defined by
their race no it's not because he's
black it's because he's Peter Parker and
I don't mean he's a clone that jackal
named after himself and left in the oven
too long
let me explain a lot of people praised
Marvel for taking the risk of creating a
black spider-man but I don't think there
was any risk involved at all Myles is
the safest and least controversial
character around because he doesn't do
anything to establish his own
personality or distinguish himself from
the other spider-man plus he's not even
the first black legacy character in
comics so he's nothing new in that
respect either no one gives John Stewart
as much praise and he predates Miles by
decades or he'll rody was Iron Man for a
pretty significant amount
I'm in the 80s and those characters are
awesome okay what if I put it like this
miles is a young insecure kid from New
York with a gifted intelligence who
aspires to being a scientist one day his
legal guardians have financial problems
he's indirectly responsible for the
death of his uncle and when he's wearing
his costume he acts more confident and
cracks jokes at the bad guys he fights
sound familiar
Miles Morales as a character is
constantly held back by Brian Michael
Bendis being too afraid to let him shine
on his own sure he works is like a
sidekick or like a little brother to
Peter Parker but his character doesn't
stand on his own like Cain or Miguel
O'Hara who are interesting because they
are so different from Peter Parker let
me demonstrate
Miguel O'Hara cracks jokes in his
personal life as a civilian but when
he's in costume he's all business
there's also different social
significance in his story for Peter as
New Yorkers look up to Miguel O'Hara and
try to emulate him because he's the
first superhero in years rather than
trash him in the media like Peter it's
spider-man as a beloved outlaw and Cain
never jokes ever Cain is trying to live
his life with the bare minimum of
responsibility and would put off jumping
into a burning building if it meant he
could finish his dinner first but he
still feels obligated to make an effort
at some point both of these guys kill
bad guys either when it's necessary or
when it suits them they both have their
own unique sets of challenges and
character interactions and give an
interesting take on what it means to
live in spider-man's shadow I'm very
confident that from the visuals alone
they're already working to make Myles
less of a reactionary character and more
proactive with his own decisions to make
you can already see the way they try to
set him apart without any dialogue he
has a very different attitude from Peter
Parker regarding casual property damage
I like the style they gave him this
urban look of wearing his hoodie and
sneakers over a suit and the spray
painted graffiti look he's added to
Peter's costume
I think that's Peter's costume he's
wearing because the original web pattern
is still visible underneath the black
paint
you can see these faded edges on the
gloves and boots and logo itself looks
quickly sprayed on he should have used
the stencil made of masking tape if you
ask me and you know he didn't have this
suit handed to him by shield in a fancy
suitcase or Iron Man he pieced it
together with what felt comfortable
that's cool stuff and gives him more
independence I also like how he visits
the grave of Peter Parker who is 27 I
guess almost like their reestablishing
his motive for taking up the mantle in
the comics miles has always had this
problem with motivation it was never
fully fleshed out why he wanted to be
spider-man he did it because why not and
every time a person of significance was
killed off it didn't give him any more
or less reason than before
Peter uncle Deadpool masks his mom his
whole universe nothing stuck with him or
bothered him for more than a single
issue in all of his time mourning these
people was off-screen and then all three
of them came back and his universe -
Myles needs his own Uncle Ben someone
who teaches him responsibility and
motivates him Peter Parker should be
that for miles
imagine this Myles finds himself with
these amazing spider powers and when he
couldn't have used them to save
spider-man he's too afraid to do
anything so he sits back and watches
Peter lose maybe this causes him to feel
weak and he decides he never wants to
stand by and let something bad happen if
he can help it again he becomes a bit of
a hothead and rushes into a bad
situation right away instead of
twiddling his thumbs going gee what
would Peter do he needs to ask the
question what would Myles do if this
movie can answer that question it will
have successfully written Miles Morales
better than the guy who created him of
course all of this is way too far away
to tell for sure if that's the plan but
it's what I'm hoping for
I want Myles to become more than just a
color swap of a different character I
want him to be awesome on his own and
think and act in new ways the trailer
gave us a glimpse of what that could
look like and
that makes me more excited for him as
the main character then I probably would
have been if it was Peter it's the
potential that miles has that I'm
looking forward to now I'm sure a lot of
other channels are combing through all
this footage and asking whether that
Prowler is Aaron Davis or Hobie Brown or
whether some random background detail
confirms a dozen characters but I want
to give my thoughts on it as a whole and
why I'm looking forward to it it's a
movie no one wanted or expected but now
that it's on its way it looks more
promising than a lot of other superhero
films when there were no expectations
for it it blew us away by looking like
something really unique and special I
for one am beyond ecstatic for this
thing because it might be the first step
in making Miles Morales really unique
and special and I think he deserves that
don't you
[Music]
[Music]